[Music]
on this Friday night a big boost for
Canada's small and medium-sized
businesses the wage subsidies the Prime
Minister is promising plus Canada's key
interest rate drops about as low as it
can go
Ontario's emergency alert to travelers
as BC reveals its worst case scenario
plus 200 Canadians stuck on a
virus-infected cruise ship and at least
four passengers have died ventilators
are like gold wire politicians in the US
fighting over them I don't believe you
need 40,000 or 30,000 plus Britain's
Prime Minister and health minister test
positive and clocking in from the
kitchen and coping with the cat perks
and perils of working from home
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
lots of developments this Friday
starting with a lifeline for companies
whose business has been killed by this
virus the federal government will
subsidize the wages of employees in
small and medium sized businesses part
of a sweeping new aid package it will
cover 75% of workers wages an increase
from 10 percent announced last week and
it will be back dated to March 15 so
employers can hire back people they've
already laid off as well the government
is offering loan guarantees for small
and medium sized businesses of $40,000
and it will be interest-free for one
year our hope is that employers who are
being pushed towards laying off people
because of kovat 19 we'll think again
and for those you who've already had to
lay off workers we hope you will
consider rehiring them given this
payroll support the Bank of Canada is
also moving quickly it slashed its
benchmark interest rate again reducing
it to 0.25 percent that's the lowest the
Bank believes it can go governor Stephen
poloz also announced plans to buy up
debt to try to keep money circulating in
the economy he says he's doing all he
can to keep the pandemic from tanking
the economy a no firefighter ever got
criticized for using too much water
all of this is designed to keep business
as afloat through the worst of this so
that they can get up and running again
when it's over David Aiken reports a
barbershop its chairs now empty for two
weeks we have to think this this
decision safety for my team and for my
clientele but a decision that comes with
costs with no revenue thousands of
business owners have had to layoff
employees but now new help which Ottawa
hopes will let business owners bring
back some workers a massive wage subsidy
employers will see the federal
government cover 75% of the payroll back
dated to March 15th I think it's good
it's a good percentage and so very I
feel it's very good for the Canadian
citizen in addition a new government
back loan worth $40,000 businesses can
also defer submitting their gst/hst and
other federal taxes until June that's a
move that amounts to an interest-free
loan now many details will not be
announced until next week
how big a business for example will be
eligible for the wage subsidy and will
there be a cap but one of the federal
government's goals with these measures
is to slow the number of new employment
insurance claims claims made at service
canada centers centers which the federal
government closed to the public Friday
out of safety concerns also to our
members that are serving the government
wants to move all applications for AI
online or to the phone a move many found
frustrating their offices are all shut
you can't talk to anyone try calling the
phone lines call first thing in the
morning the lines busy you can't get
through the call demand is ridiculous
now these new measures for small and
medium-sized business obviously are for
immediate relief but they're also
important to help keep employers and
their workforce together and that is
going to be critical to make sure the
economic recovery is as strong as it can
be and as quick as it can be once this
health crisis passes Donna
okay David akin in Ottawa thank you
let's look at the numbers now everyone's
watching the numbers across the country
more than 700 new cases were confirmed
across Canada today BC had 67 new cases
Quebec once again had the biggest daily
spike 392 new cases there 10 more people
died in Quebec that brings the death
toll there to 18 in Canada more than
4,700 people have now tested positive 55
people have died every province and
territory except Nunavut has detected
the virus and as you can see the numbers
are going up right across the country
Quebec Ontario Alberta and British
Columbia are hardest hit Ontario Health
Minister Christine Elliot said that
province is using every tool possible to
inform the public about the critical
steps they must follow to limit the
spread of this virus Ontario has been
sending out emergency alerts to cell
phones radios and televisions that's the
alerted demands travelers who have
recently returned to Canada must and are
required by law to stay home and self
isolate for 14 days that means no
shopping or visiting family or friends
many of the recent cases in Canada are
among people who have returned from
travelling the head of the World Health
Organization says the chronic global
shortage of personal protective
equipment or PPE is now one of the most
urgent threats to our collective ability
to save lives without that gear health
care workers get sick in some cases
they're dying PPE and ventilators are
now a far more precious commodity than
oil we're hearing already about
rationing and shortages in Canada and as
Abigail Beeman reports some doctors or
even soliciting donations we have over
10,000 hits across the websites and it's
essentially a resource for the public to
know what they can donate dr. Sonny Joe
Hall is an emergency physician so
concerned about personal protective
equipment on the front lines
he started mask a hero connecting
donations with hospitals in BC and
Ontario that need them some hospitals
are already rationing masks Thursday
Prime Minister
Trudeau promised more equipment millions
more items that are necessary but when
will they actually get to hospitals in
need I can't give you an exact time or
date for all of the various pieces and
types of equipment but rest assured that
we're looking across the globe and also
obviously in Canada the federal
government is working with the provinces
and territories and their different
needs as officials everywhere stressed
the need to stay home and keep physical
distance BC now has early evidence that
it's working the planning that's being
done should allow us to to adequately
care for everybody who needs it so much
of that depends on us all doing our part
to keep this to keep this from going
explosively there is also worry about
enough equipment for patients as well as
health care workers we have limited
number of ventilators we know a certain
proportion of these patients will
require critical care and ventilation
support so I worry about that being
exceeded and deaths being higher than
they need to that scenario being planned
for - we intend to have ventilators
available to whomever needs them but yes
the we have an ethicist that is at the
command table we are building out an
ethical framework choices about who gets
help no one wants to have to make
abigail Beaman Global News Ottawa
it's obvious we can't wait to see what's
coming to react we know what could be
coming we've had 12 weeks to get ready
buy equipment and restrict people's
movements governments are preparing
worst-case scenarios and today British
Columbia made public its projections if
what happened in China or Italy happened
in BC with the healthcare system be able
to cope Erik Sorenson reports the Linn
Valley care center in North Vancouver
saw Canada's first death from kovat 19
and showed how the virus could spread bc
health officials are modeling
expectations to manage this
unpredictable virus they're comparing BC
with outbreaks elsewhere that's B C's
new cases where the star is it's nothing
like what is happening in northern Italy
the blue bars but officials have to be
ready for the worst they would hope to
maximize the number of beds to some
20,000 then they could handle a South
Korea type epidemic with beds to spare
only in a worst-case scenario like
northern Italy's hospital based epidemic
could there be a shortage of beds the
most serious model the one the northern
Italy type epidemic the hospital based
one which we do not foresee but which we
have to prepare for you see a shortage
of beds here and only here in every
jurisdiction this is the big risk a
surge in kovat 19 cases beyond the
capacity of the healthcare system beyond
the capacity of your local hospital you
can get more beds and more ventilators
and increase that capacity but what
needs to happen is for people to stay at
home to reduce the spread that will
bring the peak of the curve down so
hospitals can manage the crisis it would
be for a longer period but could avoid a
worst case scenario Saskatchewan has
also modeled what could happen if a
quarter of its population got the virus
elite Saskatchewan Health Authority
documents stated worst case demand for
acute services will exceed existing
capacity for hospital beds ICU beds and
ventilators and the very worst case a
death toll of 15,000 in that province
but it's just a planning tool what
actually will result in Saskatoon for
the plan is not what's on that page it
was to give an example
health officials must prepare for all
possibilities and the public must be
trusted to do what's right if we can get
HP
flattened quickly by everybody just
staying calm and being rational about
our choices and what we choose to do
then then it shows that we can be
trusted to make good sound decisions
some forecasts may seem alarmist but
public trust comes from knowing the
honest scenarios the best and the worst
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto
another cruise ship is infected with the
corona virus and more than 240 Canadians
are on board the and for passengers on
that Holland America ship have died the
Zaandam is waiting to navigate through
the Panama Canal more than 1,800 people
are on board about a hundred and fifty
of them were told are sick they will
remain on board the healthy passengers
we're told will be transferred to
another ship the captain announced the
deaths today Holland America says the
four people who died were older guests
the death toll in Spain soared overnight
769 people died in one day from Kovac 19
another 7800 people became infected
health officials there though do say the
number is beginning to stabilize almost
5000 people have died in Spain and
hospitals are full they're short of
supplies and are at the breaking point
today Spain's Health Ministry confirmed
that more than 9,000 health care workers
are infected with koban 19 that's nearly
15 percent of all the confirmed cases in
that country and in the UK the death
toll jump by a hundred and eighty one in
24 hours and the thousands of infected
now include the two top political
leaders heading up the Cova 19 response
Prime Minister Boris Johnson and his
health minister there now self isolating
but what happens if they become
seriously ill and who else did they
infect hears crystal commencing I've
developed mild symptoms of the corona
virus that's to say a temperature and a
persistent cough Prime Minister Boris
Johnson's positive diagnosis was just
the start in his video he was calm and
pledged to keep going with the important
work to protect public health but then
his health secretary posted his own
video I was
tested and that test has been positive
so I'll be self isolating here until
next Thursday professor Chris Witte is
the face of the UK's public awareness
campaign to help save lives stay at home
anyone can spread coronavirus he also
has the question now did these
individuals infect anyone else people
are supposed to be in a lockdown only
going out when it's absolutely necessary
and we've all been instructed to keep
our distance from one another the rate
of infection has been doubling every
three to four days officials say it's
not a matter of advice being ignored but
proof the pandemic does not discriminate
there is some good news
health care workers will be given a
blood test to see if the virus is in
their system this will be antigen
testing testing whether people currently
have the disease so that our health and
social care workers can have security in
the knowledge that they are safe to
return to work if their test is negative
frontline staff say for them those tests
are as important as masks and gloves
crystal the Man Singh Global News London
the US president is venting about
ventilators coming up his mixed messages
about the need for the life-saving
equipment
you
the united states now the epicenter of
the outbreak in the world has more than
100,000 confirmed cases of copán 19
there are certain to be many more
because there has been limited testing
so far more than 1500 people in the US
have now died the virus is accelerating
across the country but New York City is
still the worst many hospitals there are
already jammed with patients ventilators
are being shared while political leaders
argue about what needs to happen next
Jackson prosecco reports already filled
beyond capacity
New York's hospitals are stretching
doctors and nurses to their limits it's
been like a war zone
a medical war zone of working with
limited resources makeshift morgues and
refrigerated trucks are being used to
store bodies the first 1000 bed
temporary hospital is still not finished
and the governor is already planning to
build eight more across the state now
we're looking at about 21 days for a
possible apex so we want to do
everything we can to be ready for that
more than 400 New York City police
officers and 200 firefighters have
tested positive for the virus calls to
911 beyond anything the city has ever
seen in a 24 hour time period we did
over 6500 calls which is a record for
EMS the governor has issued a plea for
Washington to step up and provide 30,000
ventilators to meet expected demand but
on Thursday night the president cast
doubt on the need a lot of the numbers
that are being said in some areas are
just bigger than they're going to be I
don't believe you need 40,000 or 30,000
ventilated on Friday Trump reversed
course he's now requiring General Motors
to make ventilators using the wartime
defense production act meanwhile the
situation grows more dire by the day as
case numbers surge in Michigan Georgia
and Illinois hospitals now have to make
tough choices about which patients they
can treat doctors have even turned to
the black market for basic supplies they
can't get anywhere else we came together
as an organization and we said we
to protect each other first if we're
going to be able to serve the community
American lawmakers passed a two trillion
dollar economic bailout it was signed
into law by President Trump it provides
direct payments to American citizens
who've lost their jobs and bails out big
corporations and airlines it is the
first but likely not the last bailout
that will be needed Donna all right
Jackson Prosecco in Washington thank you
still ahead how Canadian businesses are
shifting gears to give back during this
pandemic there has never been a greater
need for a whole range of medical
supplies all around the world like there
is right now hand sanitizers gloves
masks face shields and other protective
equipment
not to mention ventilators many large
Canadian companies are switching their
production lines to help and as Mike
Armstrong reports smaller companies for
stepping up to this is a brand new
production line being built from scratch
to make a product this company doesn't
sell we have no intention to make this
as a business you've done so how's the
president of ad fast it makes
construction products like sealants and
paints usually the goal is to be up and
running producing hand sanitizer by next
week and they're not talking about small
batches well we have a capacity of
approximately 32,000 litres a day dr.
Haas says he'll sell his new product at
only the cost of the ingredients the
company's paying to the labor he's even
willing to share the design of the
production line in case other companies
want to jump on board online available
pictures writing everything
the critical shortage of medical
supplies could cost lives more
ventilators are needed for patients
while protective gear is desperately
needed for the healthcare workers
treating those patients well some
companies are stepping up the right
thing you know aqua Zanna is shifting
production at his Quebec Factory instead
of making jeans he's now buying fabric
to manufacture hospital scrubs Canada
Goose is shifting some production to
making gowns and scrubs and Labatt after
brewing beer for 170 years is now also
producing hand sanitizer this plant
north of Montreal has a new product
Bauer hockey says it's now making face
shields for healthcare workers that in
this crisis everyone's on the same team
well they have teammates a group of 3d
printers in southern Ontario says it's
producing shields to help until big
manufacturers can ramp up what we're
saying it's about time to get back now
doctor is appealing to other companies
to step forward calling on anyone who
can pitch in to fight a common enemy
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
home bound from nine to five next the
perks and quirks of working from home
we know you're tired and stressed and
that practically everything in your life
has changed in a matter of weeks that
includes millions of people who are now
working from home so we want to end
tonight with a lighter look at the
perils and unpredictability of working
from home here's Mike Joel a it's
official the so called Cove annual
generation is driving us insane this
dad's face screams isolation and if it's
not kids
it's our pets maybe it's the quarantine
talking but I think cats are up to
something
they're always there pawing at something
or sitting in a devious way it's
different with dogs and all their tail
wag isolation has taught us a lot about
ourselves and the tighty-whitey
underwear choice of our colleague
spouses we've also learned about
technology like turning off cameras
sometimes the hard way and my producer
Catherine learned the art of video
bombing from her roommate it's a lesson
he could have learned from this man who
rose to fame because of his kids and who
now is seemingly given up trying to keep
them out of his office perhaps he knows
there's no refuge hey I found you
yeah sure did working from home will
either drive us batty or get us to laugh
at silly things like rappers party B
jumping through Jenga or Rita Wilson
clearly kids at home aren't an issue for
celebrities microlight global news
Toronto I think it's the cats that are
loving this the most that is global
national for this Friday I'm Jonah
Friesen staying home helped stop the
spread just a reminder and we leave you
tonight with some encouragement to take
courage
[Music]
that's tragically hip guitars Paul
Langlois and his family leading a
sing-along of courage from their porch
we hope you can keep your spirits up
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves
bye bye
[Music]